how can you promote your product so I
just recently kicked off my book launch
campaign and I'm super excited about it
and I thought that I would share today
some of the things I'm doing to promote
my book and how you can use that to help
promote your products and services one
of the things that I'm a big believer of
is you need to provide value where I
think people are just trying to sell too
much you're trying to sell sell sell
sell sell your products or service and
you're not getting reaction and if I
look at your social media accounts and
look at your newsletters it's just one
big sales pitch and people don't care
about that people will get bored super
quick and so a great way to do that is
to talk about your product in your
service and the creation of it and the
value that it provides so as an example
with this book series this is week 60 I
don't know 60 something 62 ish
let me see 60 61 was close 61 I've been
talked about the book for 61 weeks and
only last week that I even tell you guys
what it was about and you're tuning in
every week because I'm providing value
because I'm answering questions because
I'm talking about the process because
you guys are writing in and I'm giving
you the answers to what you're looking
for and so you could do the same thing
with your product or service because at
the same time I get to talk about my
book and promote my book every time even
though it doesn't feel like a hard sell
and I don't want to give you guys a hard
sell it's not the intention of what I'm
doing every week and so if you're
creating a new product a new service you
could do it behind the scenes you could
showcase how you make it you can talk
about the ups and downs and the
strugglers and the failures and then the
highs and the winds and take people
along their journey so they're way more
tied to what it is that you're creating
and I found to be super helpful
interesting and again I didn't talk
about the title of the book until over a
year of making these video so you don't
have to go that crazy you don't have to
take it that long just part of our
marketing strategy I guess I didn't want
to release the title till we had an
opportunity for people to buy it
the next thing I'm doing is trying to
incorporate it into my content my
regular content in a way that fits so I
don't want to end every video saying go
buy my book now is the best thing
it's gonna change your life I don't want
to be I don't want to be that guy who's
just screaming at you - bye bye bye so I
have to find ways that talking about the
book will help and be relevant to the
conversation so as an example the book
is about helping you find your one word
for me believe you know for you might be
something totally different and once you
find that it gives you a lot of clarity
it's a process that I absolutely believe
in can transform your business and your
life and so that's why I spent all that
time researching and writing the book so
what I'm doing now I updated all my
social accounts so you see my face and
you see a picture of the book on my
YouTube the channel art and some of the
other social sites it'll say Evan
Carmichael believe in underneath what's
your one word at the end of the videos
now I'm starting to say and continue to
believe or whatever your one where it is
and we'll see you soon to get people
thinking it's an indirect call out I
guess to the book it creates curiosity
people think what's my one word oh hey
there's the book about how to find you
one word it's interesting without it
being a hard sell and hopefully also to
help you were to remind yourself that
when you have found your one word what
you do know what you stand for that's a
daily reminder for you to live up to
that and to not bow down and be afraid
because of whatever might be happening
or some big challenges going on in your
life
and so those two things I find super
helpful I think there's always gonna be
a core group of people around you who
would just inste by anything that you
create you know I'm super preciate of
the of the fans who would just buy
anything that I put out without even
knowing what it is that's that's some
hardcore loyalty I appreciate the love
means a lot to me and I have to deliver
because you'll only do that once right
if if you do it once and and the product
sucks you're not gonna do it again but
for most people they want to learn a
little bit more about it they want to
know you like you trust you before they
buy and so those two things of creating
regular content around the product or
service that you're creating that's
helpful this educational that is
interactive so you can find ways to keep
talking about it without having to
promote it all the time and then to
integrating that into the rest of your
marketing activities in a way that makes
sense that's not over the top that's not
overbearing but fits naturally into the
content that you're already creating so
those
that's my plan at least hopefully you
can learn from it having a good launch
page is also super helpful and valuable
and relevant and we'll link up the one
that we used or are using right now
because we haven't launched we haven't
finished the launch yet hopefully you
can learn some of those things to apply
to your next campaign as well let's get
to the questions first up is Charles
Chen TV he wanted to say why not title
the book hashtag believe that's an
interesting question Charles and you
know I think it that might be an easy
title for me to do it was never one of
the hurdles I considered although you
know I wear it on my shirt and there's a
big part of the branding mostly because
it didn't want it to be about just me
and I didn't want believe to have to be
your word and what you stand for I think
a lot of you guys like believe if you
didn't if you don't like believe you're
not a fan of the channel right like it's
hard to watch all these videos and not
like believe some how you would have
been really turned off on me at this
point and you know I watching even this
video but I didn't want to say that your
word has to be believed just because
it's impactful for me and changed my
life it doesn't mean that that's what's
right for you and really it's about the
process that I went through to find mine
but more importantly the process that
you can go through step by step to help
you find yours and so I wanted to make
it much more focused on you the reader
and have an impact more than just
talking about me and my story because
it's great to be inspired by somebody
but it's useless if you're not if you
taking action on it so it's meant to be
a handbook to guide you step by step to
find your one word and have an impact on
your life and give you them direction be
able to do that great question though
next up J rise thanks for the shout out
bro honored to help it all rise J rise
is actually here working on the landing
page making it rise would come in come
in
here's J rise get special guest
appearance J rise what do you what do
you want to say to this this guy J rise
here who's who saying thanks for the
show - I love that guy he is pretty epic
if you guys like at the landing page and
everything that that's on there most of
the the vision and creativity came from
J horizon even now he looks at he's like
I'm not satisfied with it we need to
update it we need to make it better and
needs
rise and so that's what he's doing right
now as I record this video next up
Antoine that's awesome news Evan
Congrats again Thank You Antoine
what a beautiful title did you find it
right away or did it come late in the
writing process can't wait to read it I
might come to Toronto to have my copy
signed and to meet you not so much a
long way from Montreal I'd be awesome to
come and meet you again it's in December
when it comes out there's a whole bunch
of book bonuses that you get immediately
but the actual copy you get in December
so after that I would love to have you
come down and meet and come to TDS and
and it'll be awesome to sign that for
you and just with a title so let me tell
this story is an interesting story my my
publisher and my agent wanted me to
write a book more of my agent they're
like I need you need to write a book
it's super-important it'll help you get
out there more it's important for your
brand and your authority and I didn't
want to write a book and like I don't
need a book like I can open doors with
my youtube channel I can open doors with
what I have already yeah you know like
the the status symbol of a book that you
need to have a book to get speaking gigs
and to get brand deals and to have
authority and be respected by the media
I feel like it's still there to some
extent but it's rapidly diminishing and
there's other ways to get that notoriety
and so I didn't really want to write a
book but hehe said okay well let's just
like go through the exercise go through
the process you know so give me a title
for a book you'd be an overview this
wasn't the book it was gonna be on
modeling success I didn't have a title
for but that was a theme about modeling
says just like we do on this channel and
I wrote a sample chapter an overview of
what it would look like and and he
pitched it and I and I got a literary
agent because of that original pitch and
then as we were thinking about okay how
can we take this idea to publishers and
what would we need to do I came up with
your one word and I said you know what
guys this is the book that I want to
write not the one that you know you guys
just want me to write a book and I just
threw something together but I want to
write this like I need to write this
book this is super helpful it's gonna
have a way bigger impact and at first
actually weren't on board they didn't
like it they didn't see the value of it
and they didn't think it was a book they
thought it was just like a worksheet or
something didn't understand how it could
be a whole book and I ended up writing
two full books and half of it was cut
out of this edition
an issue was called one word and we
added the your just to make it more
personal so you can see that it's your
one word and that we each have our own
word and there may be overlap the one
word was set pretty much from the
beginning I said I want to write this
book called one word and then the yours
was added some word later on so but
there wasn't the initially the book that
they wanted me to write but is the one
that I made them change like if I'm
writing the book this is it
next up is a car each adora your book is
coming out on my birthday
isn't that what keep it up I think that
is what I think we need to have a
birthday December six celebration for
the book coming out and I can reach his
birthday message me
we'll find something we'll find a way to
set that up next up Ricardo Martin's
we're can I get the audio version I'm so
pissed off at the audio guys right now
they don't have the version ready yet
for pre-order it's not that hard to set
up but all of the audio links don't work
there will be audio versions too audible
and wherever else you get audiobooks but
none of them work right now so the
option is not there
you only get the hardcover or the the
e-book right now and for the multiple
book bonuses if you get 10 bucks or 100
bucks or 500 books or 25 bucks there's
different bonuses those only relate to
the physical copy of the book but there
will be a one book option for the audio
version I'm just upset that they weren't
they didn't have it ready on time we
actually launched it with it and then
you click on the links and all of them
say cannot be found book does not exist
and and we thought that would be a
pretty terrible user experience for you
guys so I'm working I'm pounding my
publisher said guys come on let's go and
you know unfortunately doesn't the
industry doesn't work as quickly as we
would like it to as entrepreneurs but as
soon as this app I will let you guys
know and again like thank you so many
you guys have asked about the audio
version super appreciate it very
humbling and we're we're doing our best
to get it up it's uh I'm with you it's
painful next up mr. Louie 2050 Congrats
Evan so proud of you way to go we'll
definitely be picking up some copies
super appreciate that Louie means a lot
to me and for everybody buying it means
a lot to me with one book you get a
number
says a lot of people have asked me for
something from my time but can you help
me can you consult with me can you give
me feedback on this idea can you be my
mentor you know I think I am trying to
do that with the videos I just can't
reach everybody individually and so I
don't do consulting I don't do mentoring
it there's no one-on-one you know
package here that I'm selling and so I
offered that through the books so at the
various different levels you have an
opportunity to ask me questions or
multiple questions or a coaching call or
a mentoring package we'll see how much
it takes off I kind of wanted to take
off because you know the book sales
would be great but I kind of don't want
it to take off because that's a ton of
my time but then I kind of want to take
off because I like investing the time to
help you guys grow and it shows a
commitment it's not just like hey answer
my youtube question but that I don't do
anything with it you know here you're on
you're putting your putting money down
to buy the books and hopefully read it
and give it to your friends as well and
so I'm curious to see how that works out
and to be able to spend some one-on-one
time with some of you guys have been
sergeant putting it in order next week
Congrats Evan on the book Thank You Evan
that's a fantastic name you have by the
way really appreciate that order
next up new future builder again
Congrats great response to the question
for the designer it's been amazing seen
this journey for those that want to put
out successful book is obvious how much
time and effort it truly takes over a
year to even reach the pre-order stage
that is dedication yeah I thought it
would be fun to show the behind the
scenes I thought it'd be fun to kind of
carry you guys along the journey with me
I'm a first time off I mean I've written
a lot of stuff but I haven't written a
book that's been published by major
publisher so how's the first-time author
I thought you guys could learn along
with me and for those of you who want to
make a book you'll see what you have to
go through to get it done I hadn't seen
anybody do it and I thought let's
document the process so I'm glad that
you guys are enjoying it and are joining
me and and I like this format where it
kind of come up with a topic to rant
about and then answer your guys
questions from from the last episode so
so far it's working it's a lot of fun
for me and I'm glad you guys are seeing
the value too
next up Natalie Evan when possible share
your favorite chapter or ideal around
the book look forward to hearing from
you always the book is divided into
three sections core campaign company
core is more about finding your own word
campaign isn't about using that in your
marketing and company isn't about
building
our company around it the core is the
easiest part to grab and the most
immediately impactful the campaign is
the the candy to say okay well this like
help me get more sales right a lot of
entrepreneurs they don't see all the
problems in our business they just want
more sales get me more money and so
that's the point of the campaign section
and then the company is maybe the
hardest to digest because it's so over
overreaching it's every area of a
business to be able to build seven
figure eight figure nine figure
businesses my favorite though is the
core because that's the core like that's
a start that's that's a lot of
introspection that you have to take and
walking people through it was so
interesting for me to see the changes
that they immediately had to make in
their lives and a lot of people who I
gave the book to the pre you know the
pre book before it got published my kind
of test audience they weren't
entrepreneurs like half of the group was
not entrepreneurs and they all loved it
which is super interesting because I
wanted to give it to people I the
entrepreneurs I know we're gonna love it
the non entrepreneurs I want to see if I
could kind of kick up that little inner
entrepreneur within them the response
was super insane and it's interesting to
see how much life changes they made as a
result of identifying their one word you
know if you're unhappy with your life
there's a lot of things that might be
inconsistent with how you should be
living and most people don't live life
on purpose they're just constantly
reacting to things that are happening
around them and most people don't know
what they stand for they don't know who
they are and so you're constantly just
bouncing around from one thing to
another without a solid plan and a solid
direction and so once you once you
discover your one word once you discover
who you are truly are and have always
been and always will be that identifies
a clear path for you to be able to move
forward now on purpose and it's always
interesting that see people wants to
realize what it is it's exciting but
also scary because it means like you
immediately see the things in your life
that you should not be doing anymore or
the people who you should not be hanging
out with anymore and changing that can
be scary for some people it's a lot of
change that they have to do
but when people go through it you know I
did it with one of the instructors that
at Toronto dine salsa and the growth
that she's had from a couple
conversations and from reading the book
has just been insane and I'm so proud of
her
and she was ready for it and some people
are more ready for it than others some
people are ready for the truth and ready
to take change and and actually start
living their life and others take a
little bit more time because making that
transition can be really scary
Juwan congratulations you're an
inspiration I will write my book as well
yeah I'm curious to figure out how many
you guys are now gonna write a book or
or how much this process that I'm going
through has helped you understand the
book industry I try to make the topics
not just related to the books but try to
tie it to a broader perspective to help
you with your business
but for those of you who are really
interested in writing the book I'm you
know curious if I know how much this
series has helped you or has inspired
you to want to go out and write a book
so that's you leaving the comments I'm
super curious to find out next up is
Rhonda Congrats I've now pre-ordered it
I sent a copy of the receipt to the
email as you instructed yes so for those
of you who are buying it's super
important that you send us the receipt
to the email address that's on the
landing page we don't get information
from Amazon Barnes and Noble all that
until way late it's an industry that is
super backwards and super frustrating to
deal with and so like after you order
from Amazon I don't get a notification
that you order from Amazon and so in
order to get the bonuses that are
attached to each purchase you just have
to forward a copy of your receipt to the
email address and and make sure to
please do that because we've invested a
lot of time in in making these awesome
bonuses and and J rises over there
slaving away on the page because he
wants to see it rise and so I want to
make sure that you get the bonuses to
help you and they come right now you
don't have to wait till December it
comes immediately so you can benefit
from it
the other thing was for the for the
pre-orders the data that we get we send
to the publisher so when you send us an
email and says okay I bought from
Wisconsin I bought from Santa Barbara or
I bought from New York or whatever it is
we send that data to the bookstores and
then they're more likely to stock the
book in that area so you
for every book that we sell from toronto
the toronto bookstores are going to want
to buy more to have in the store because
they see the demand and so if you want
more of the book to be in your local
area it really helps us to have the data
to say hey this this city this postal
code they're ordering a lot so let's
make sure that those bookstores have
more copies so that really helps also
with the people who are overseas we've
already had orders from France and
Singapore and all around the world and
I've done my best to leave French video
thank-you messages that's been a fun and
interesting challenge that helps us
identify kind of overseas markets and
potential future editions for different
languages so do we do a French version
do we do a Chinese version do we do a
Spanish version a lot of the pre-order
data helps us make those decisions so it
not only lets you get some free bonuses
and some instant gratification so you
don't have to wait till Jane or December
so January December December it also
helps me with the data to be able to get
more books out into those local markets
so that's really why do the pre-order
campaigns so they get data on where
people want them
next up or rest day 2103 I would really
love to have a Facebook group with
believe nation that would be Austin Evan
great video by the way will pre-order
the book thank you for the support it's
been interesting we've had a number of
people who say they want a community off
of YouTube and the efforts that we've
had haven't really taken off I don't
know what the execution would be if is a
Facebook group if it's an email list if
it's a forum none of them have really
taken off I'm open to suggestions
so far the best spot seems to be on
YouTube itself and people come back
every day in the comments and support
each other and update each other and I'm
super happy with that and how it's going
if you guys really do see a way to
expand the beyond and you want to set up
a Facebook group or a Facebook page let
me know I mean I'm always using support
in it I want to reach an impact more
entrepreneurs so if that helps you guys
stay motivated and stay connected and
sit together then I'm willing to explore
we just haven't had a lot of success in
the past it doesn't mean we can't going
forward just our execution hasn't been
great so far so looking forward to your
feedback
next up is Lee Garfield Congrats heaven
on your book I look forward
in the coming months I'm not usually a
bookworm reading books prefer to skim
instead but I do like reading articles
including tech stuff and art related I
shall keep a lookout on your for your
book when it comes available on Amazon
much appreciated
thank you lead that really means a lot
that if you're not a regular book reader
that you would want to pick this up I
actually designed it for people who
don't like to read huge long books it's
designed so that it's super easy to stop
at any point you know every page is a
stop and you can put something in and
then quickly catch up because I found
myself I'm the kind of guy who I would
read three pages four pages five pages
of the book and then whatever my glide
lays over and I totally forgot what I
just read and so I got to go back and
read those pages again or I'm trying to
rush like I flip her head see how many
pages are left in this chapter I got 25
more pages in this chapter and so it's
frustrating to kind of stop in the
middle of a chapter so from my own
reading experience I want to design
something that was easy to read and my
publisher hated it my publisher said
this isn't how books are typically done
we don't like it too many cuts but I
wanted something that was designed to be
easy to read and a lot of people English
isn't their first language or you know
you just you want things in chunks and
you want to be able to put the book down
and pick it back up and it still all
makes sense
I don't expect someone to sit there and
read the whole thing in one sitting
although that's happened you know I
designed to be easy to read and that was
super important for me based on my own
reading style and Nina who doesn't read
any books love that the format to it so
I knew I was onto a good start so that
means a lot it should be available on
Amazon in the UK if it's not let me know
I don't look into it another thing to
add to my list but super important for
you guys to be able to get access to the
book
next up Simeon fantastic definitely
pre-order the book I really like the
other packages as well when I saw that I
can meet you and talk with you by buying
one of your bigger packages I felt
really excited unfortunately
circumstances are that I can't afford it
but one day I will meet you and have a
chat with you written down on my to-do
list so one day I can achieve this dream
thank you very much for all the content
you give us you're my idol lots of love
I really appreciate that man and yeah I
understand you know for some of you may
be out of reach
ordering one book means a lot to me if
you know if my channel has
giving you value you know the book is
$20 if my channel my videos are giving
you $20 a value
I appreciate that support if it's giving
you more value than that then then I
appreciate that too and if you can if
you can't afford it totally
understandable and if you can if you
gotten some results like if your
business has grown you you've gained a
hundred thousands hundreds of thousand
dollars from the content then you know
hopefully you'll consider give him back
a little bit and supporting the creator
behind it other ways to meet up though
is if you're on my newsletter list
whenever I travel I try to say where I'm
going and meet up with with fans so I
just came back from Chicago and ended up
taking a ride with somebody from the
airport getting the ride back to the
airport with two friends and they got an
hour free consulting and great to meet
them had lunch you know I put off
talking to the media because I had an
hour and 15 minute lineup of people want
to talk with me after a session and I
wanted me I was a guy who when I went to
spring training I loved seeing that the
the baseball players stood there and
signed every autograph until there was
nobody else and so I wanted to make sure
if somebody's waiting an hour to talk to
me that I was still there to be able to
have a conversation with them I have
lunch with fans and subscribers instead
of going to the VIP room and having
lunch with the big guys there's just
something I like doing to the connect
with the people who are who are part of
this and and it's interesting how a lot
of people when they go away they don't
they like to be Hermits they don't like
to meet others they just like to do
their thing where for me as long as it's
if I'm by myself you know if I'm with
Nina and Hayden this may be a different
story because I want to be together but
by myself I try to I pack my day like
when I left on my last day from Chicago
I brought everything with me I brought
my backpack full of clothes and
everything with me for the whole day
because I didn't want to have to waste
time going back to the hotel because I
wanted to spend it with with you guys
who came out and wanted to chat in
Chicago so yeah I mean that that's on
your list man that's super humbling
really appreciate that and maybe if I
come to your city we'll be able to
connect with them next up Patricia I
have my one word now I need the book to
build a business based on it can't wait
for the roadmap it's a super interesting
comment and it's partly why I wrote the
book because when I discovered what my
one word was there was no roadmap there
wasn't a buck I wish he didn't have to
write this book I wish
have to make this YouTube channel like I
just want to consume this content but
nobody was creating it so I had to go
out and make it myself you know I just
wanted to follow the road map but it
didn't exist so I had to ride it I
stumbled my way through it I'm turning
my business around believe and making
that something that could take off and
you know help me build a team and help
me have a big impact and then I went and
discovered other entrepreneurs who had
done it around there one word at various
sizes from 50,000 full-time income to
150 million dollars in revenue and they
just stumbled upon their path right and
nobody had the complete answer because
nobody has written the book so by going
through my story and those other people
we wrote the book and it's great so I
still have the the road not to refer to
I'm excited for you guys people to have
it I think it's a good lesson for
entrepreneurs to like if there's a big
need that you have for yourself you know
don't complain go out and create it
right I created the YouTube videos I
created the book a lot of the stuff that
that I created from scratch my own itch
because I'm frustrated this doesn't
exist and I need it in my life to get to
where I want to go and so I go out and
create it next up to pan con go Evan
assuming that's congratulations I love
it man when are you gonna launch the
book in India I feel like a shipping
India maybe it's not maybe it's not
international at all can you guys check
please let me know if it's on Amazon in
your country be super helpful and if
it's not I need to get on my publisher
and say listen let's let's turn it up
because believe nation wants it in their
countries let me know please leave in
the comments it would mean a lot to me
q Lee writing in Powell's when I click
pre-order does not give the pre-order
price but charges $26 and asks for a
coupon code this is an interesting thing
about the book industry there is no one
set price the full price is listed at
$26 u.s. but every day the publishers
have different prices and so I found the
best prices typically at Amazon and
Barnes & Noble
you can click through and even they're
within like it maybe it's not a big
change but one day might be 1980 the
next day is 1975 the next day is 1990
and so what I would encourage you to do
is if you're getting a high price like
26 the full price on one of the sites
then I would go check out the other ones
to see if you can get a better deal I
accept any of them I'm not making any
money off these books anyways
I accept any of them just send me the
receipt and we'll make sure that the
bonuses get off to you but I would just
know make sure you check all and the see
where you can get the best deal if
you're buying more than ten I have a
special deal with CEO Reid's where those
are set prices they're not gonna change
you get discounted price you get a ton
of bonuses we also get discounted prices
based on the quantity that you order so
that is that is set there's no problem
about that it's the one unit there's
always a suggested price but then what
the retailer does with it is up to them
so you know it's just part of the retail
game I guess and encourage you to to
shop around to find the best deal I
think I'm gonna end it there I don't
know how long this video is it's getting
long it feels long but exciting and I
know you have a lot of questions most of
them of congratulations so happy for you
and again like super peaches support
that really means a lot to me it's been
a long process to go through a lot of
love has been poured into it and so it's
great to see that you guys are excited
by it and it's some you know extra
validation and it makes me happy I'm
gonna end it there if you guys have a
question I didn't answer ask it on this
video and I'll do my best to answer it
on the next edition I'd love to hear
what you have to think about the topic
of how to promote your business back at
the very top of this show also you have
a question about my book or the book
writing process or a different question
you know leave it in the comments and
I'll do my best next week to answer it
thank you guys so much for the support
it means a lot to me
truly like reading your comments brings
a massive smile to my face fills my
heart with joy I'm walking on cloud 9
for the rest of the week thank you so
much
continue to believe or whatever year on
where it is and I'll see you soon